but it's crazy because you uh
uh being one of the first guys since
Wayne to really put on nationally out of
New Orleans not to say that there aren't
other artists by the way shout out to
currency who's [__] a legendary yeah
but he's got a new album out with uh JD
that's coming soon so I'm gonna shout
out to spitter but you had [__]
Birdman
pass you the Baton on the intro of your
album man that's crazy huh I didn't even
realize how crazy that was until like
two months ago [__] told me that I'm
like you have [__] Birdman passing
you the [__] torch officially on
record
that shit's crazy
how did you like how does that happen
like like
um I don't know I just asked him to send
me some [__] was in the studio and he
said he like that's what I want
you know kick the album off that's what
I want
and he was like I want to do this for
you yeah he just he told me the other
day like I won't be on everything you
ever released like
Birdman's one of the first people
believe in me though like two months and
three months until rapping he called me
like you the one like he didn't try
signing you yeah he tried to sign he was
the first person trying to sign me it
just didn't work out
well
like him I was too much to rap and I I
ain't released number one tape like I
got released I I got I got signed at the
three tapes the tape that I had was
called I quit because I was about to
stop rapping okay and the day I got my
cover up for a birdman called me like
man I won't sign you [__] me up you flew
me to Cali we just lost touch in like
the next week or some [__] like that I
had wind up doing say cheese I ain't
even know it would say cheese but then
Sean brought me to the league when
Capital wanted to sign me and then I was
going back and forth the lid was then so
it like [__] yeah what made you
eventually like for you because I'm sure
it's got to be kind of cool to be corded
like that it almost probably feels like
similar to like a NBA free agent feels
like when they're trying to sign to you
know a team like how cool was that just
having like a little bidding work going
for you
um
I don't know I'm ready for the next one
you know I'm gonna fulfill this deal and
then we go double back I had like ten
thousand followers and like
so they my labor called me before
anything like you know what I'm saying
so they kind of they got they looked up
like you know what I'm saying they got
in early yeah they got in there at least
they believed in you earlier they
believed the mirror that's why that's
why I ain't gonna lie like
that's why with this live I'm at right
now like I don't know anyone lead them
because they believed in me like that
that means a lot you know for sure for
sure man
um at what point in time did you realize
like vulture Island was like
an Anthem for for just a lot of people
like it's it's a it's an Anthem in the
club it's anthem when it comes to NFL
players I just realized that like last
week at boosted Bash
[__] tap me like man you got an Anthem
like she gonna be around for a minute
like
I ain't even understand it though I said
crazy because that [__] still in the
club I ain't drop I ain't dropping a
year right like no way I'm still down
there in my head like no way I'm still
relevant like
but that [__] still popping highs
popping been popping like what was boozy
bash like bus was crazy that's just
that's home though so you know of course
yeah
you know I always shut up I would say
he's one of the few guys
that if you love him when you meet him
you will not be disappointed no count
though because that's him that's him bro
for sure
okay I'll be him because you meet some
guys and they're like oh you ain't who I
grew up look you mean boozy and you're
like oh nah this is you yeah he's a he's
such a good dude too and he's so funny
like you gotta try to
during the pandemic him in trouble rest
in peace to trouble they were doing
these pool parties I'm sure you saw the
footage did you ever see any of the
footage of the trouble boozy pool
parties with all the damn cucumbers
all these [__] sucking on cucumbers
and [__] I'm trying to go to this year
bro I don't know man you got to stay out
of there man what I just feel like you
know you'll get you go you don't want to
[__] around with the wrong [__] over
there you know I mean you don't want to
[__] with no [__] sucking on cucumbers
bruh thanks though you got your whole
life ahead of you man don't throw it
away for a cucumber bra you know what I
mean
that's my type of point I like that type
of [__] you a strip club guy
um I wanna be
that's something to Aspire to be I want
to be it's like
I just can't go to the club like you
know what I'm saying something in my
head not letting me go to the club
you're smart you're smart yeah stay out
the club man I was worth it before I was
rapping I ain't never been to the club
like really I wasn't old enough so how
old are you now 24th and May 24 like so
like you never like really started to
hit the club until you were getting
booked yeah
that's the time to go when there's a bag
to pick up that's what I'm telling you
like stay out bro that's what I'm saying
I remember I tried to go to a club one
time in my city
and they told us man it was so hectic
for us to get in right that was already
I was already letting my sit around the
time like man I plan on be like
I said you know what I told bro I'm like
man let's go I said next time we come in
here they're gonna give us all their
money